Language immersion.
It's a term we hear all the time in
connection with learning languages.
I've talked a bit about it before.
I wanna talk about it now with
reference to my recent visit to Poland.
So, you know, we have language
immersion programs in school.
My grandchildren here in Vancouver
did all their schooling in French,
so they are immersed in French.
The teacher speaks in French.
All the subjects are covered in French.
As a result of that, they get a
fairly high level of comprehension.
Their speaking ability isn't necessarily
all that great, however, it is ready
to be activated at any time because
they have been immersed in the
language, they have good comprehension.
They have learned many
subjects using French.
That's one form of immersion.
You also hear people say, you know, to,
you have to, to learn the language, you
need to immerse yourself in the language.
It's a good image: you kind of
get into the pool, you get wet.
You're sort of drowning in the language.
You're immersed in the language.
But what does it really mean?
Uh, obviously if you go to a
country where you can't speak
the language or you've ha...
or you have a very limited knowledge
of the language, it's very difficult
to be immersed in the language.
You are surrounded by the language,
you're surrounded by people who speak
the language, you may hear the language
on radio or television, but you are
not really connected to the language.
You're not participating in the language.
And so many people can live in a
country where a language is spoken,
and if they don't put any effort
into learning the language, being
there alone, being immersed in the
language is not gonna do much for them.
By the same token, you can immerse
yourself in the language without being in
the country where the language is spoken.
You can read, you can listen,
you can talk to people online.
You can create sort of a language
world for yourself, which
is also a form of immersion.
Now, how does all that
relate to my visit to Poland?
So I came back, I was in Poland
for I guess six or seven days.
Really enjoyed it.
I enjoyed discovering Poland.
Uh, my wife and I flew first to
Warsaw, then turned around and
the next day went to Copenhagen.
That's just the way our
ticket was structured.
And, uh, then we worked our way
back to Poland through Sweden, and
basically from the evening of the
25th until the, you know, midday of
the 2nd of June, we were in Poland.
Half of the time, roughly spent in Warsaw.
Half of it spent in Kraków which is, uh,
one of the historical capitals of Poland.
Now, since I was there with my wife,
mostly we were speaking English.
My attempts at speaking Polish despite
having spent two months prior to going,
you know, listening to a lot of Polish,
reading, a lot of Polish, I had one
italki lesson before going, uh, that's
not really immersion, but it's a start
towards immersing myself in the language.
Uh, eight years ago I had a program
of three months where I did the same.
So, and I had committed to doing two
interviews in Polish when in Poland.
And these took place in, uh, Kraków.
So prior to going, I had attempted
to use my Polish on the flight,
going over, uh, with taxi drivers,
with very limited success.
I was very much aware of my limitations,
and yet arriving in Kraków on the 29th,
I had an interview entirely in Polish.
For Easy Polish, uh, a website.
I'll leave a link in the description box.
Uh, I am in fact following up
with them to see if I can get at
least a part of that interview
and put it up here on my channel.
So you can see me struggling in a
combination of Slavic languages, lot
of mistakes, however, communicating.
So the important thing there is
that for, I think it was 10 or
15 minutes, maybe it was longer.
I was communicating in Polish, so I was
hearing polish, I was hearing polish
having to do with the subject that
we were discussing, and so therefore,
that input is very relevant to me.
It's what I call very high resonance
because I'm very much involved in it.
I can't be wandering, my attention
can't be wandering somewhere else.
I have to pay attention to what people
are saying, so I'm getting that input.
I'm making mistakes while speaking.
Um, aware of some of the
mistakes as I'm making them.
Uh, if I see a video of the
interview, I will be aware
of more mistakes that I make.
And all of this, it does kind
of nudge me in the direction of
speaking better because I start
to notice things in the language.
Uh, maybe I'm, you know, I'm
aware of many rules that I
can't really apply on the fly.
Uh, but then I notice when I see myself
in a video that I made this or that
mistake, I know it's a mistake, but
in the heat of the moment speaking, I
couldn't produce the language correctly.
But that is a form of, of immersion.
Uh, the next day I had another interview
uh, with a gentleman, Maciej Wieczorek,
who is a motivational speaker in Poland.
He does these interviews in his
Bentley, which is his studio, and we
drive around the city and he asks me
questions and we spoke in a number
of languages including Polish, and
that will also go up on his channel.
I will, at some point make
you aware of where that, you
know, where you can see that.
Again, I struggled in my Polish, I
struggled in some of the other languages.
Again, it's a form of immersion.
Even if you're doing poorly, it's
a form of immersion because you are
involved in speaking with someone.
But I think also, like on my way back,
first of all, we had a meetup in Warsaw
and one of the at attendants was an
American will who lives in Gdańsk.
And uh, he gave me this book, which is
a story told by someone describing life
in Poland, uh, before the outbreak of
the Second World War, and a very kind
of, well, he came down from Gdańsk.
And he even wrote a little, you know,
uh, dedication message here, thanking
me for the influence that I have had on
his attitude towards language learning.
A very positive person is Will and
I thank him very much for the book.
I picked up a lot of books in Poland.
I can never resist going to bookstores.
I bought a bunch of books.
My luggage, luggage was
much heavier going back.
I've also found audiobooks and eBooks
on history, uh, from publio, uh,
.pl, which I've imported into LingQ.
I've been reading them.
I also did find the digital
version of this book.
And so I've been doing that on
LingQ alternating between reading
it online and reading it on paper.
Uh, this book, I couldn't find any
digital version of it, but I read the
whole thing on the plane coming back.
And I've often said that when you read
a, a paper book away from the internet,
The whole book, the, your first book is
like a major milestone in the language.
So all of the things that, and, and
to me this is a form of, of immersion.
Uh, it takes a long time for this
passive vocabulary to, to crystallize, to
activate, to where you're actually able
to use this, and you do eventually have to
put yourself into situations where you're
using these words all the time, but you
are really building up your capability,
you're developing your comprehension.
It is a form of immersion, just
like, uh, kids like my grandchildren
in French immersion in Canada.
It's mostly passive.
It's mostly hearing the language.
It's mostly learning things
through the language, but I also
consider that a form of immersion.
Uh, it's just simply not
practical always to speak.
Speaking is one form of immersion, largely
because of the input that you get back.
Uh, but listening and
reading is also immersion.
Visiting Poland, seeing Kraków,
interacting even in a limited way with
Polish people, seeing how they live,
eating their food, getting a sense of
their history, traveling in the country,
traveling on their trains, uh, having
a coffee on the square in Kraków.
All of these things are immersing
you in the language, the culture, the
history, the environment of the language.
It's all part of immersion.
So immersion is not just sitting
down with someone and speaking.
Immersion is getting involved with
everything that relates to that
language, building up your passive
capability, which is going to form the
base then for your active capability.
So I think the definition of immersion
should be much broader than just going
to a country and assuming you can
start speaking to people, you can't.
There's so many things, so many
ways you can immerse yourself in
the language before going so that
when you do go there, you can get
greater advantage from the potential
immersion opportunities that are there.
Uh, I am determined to continue with
my reading and passive immersion
activities on LingQ where I have a
number of books on, uh, Polish history.
And it's good to do something like
history using different resources.
Just like with the language,
you wanna cover the same ground
using different resources.
And I think that, uh, already now, I think
my capability to speak would be better
than it was when I arrived in Kraków.
And if I give myself another few weeks
here with Polish history and, and other
resources like this book here, which
I have both on LingQ to look up the
words and reading it on paper to have
a different kind of experience, um,
I think my capability will improve.
And, uh, I will try to schedule a
discussion, another discussion in Polish
in two weeks to a month as I continue
along in my immersion program in Polish.
And the final thing was I
was very surprised by Poland.
Very positive country,
uh, energetic people.
A lot of things work very well.
Many people out on the streets in
the evenings enjoying themselves.
We had a great time.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.